how in general would you describe your
style I want to see heads look up smile
has always been something I care about
[Music]
[Music]
I'm like okay well alaikum Salaam I
never become a Muslim I'm actually
walking around New York City making la
ilaha illaallah just walking around I
can't do those things I couldn't I was
saying the same thing to myself right up
until I took my shot I can't do those
things man think of it I was getting
high and drinking and smoke and doing
all these things the day before I took
my Shahada and I give you knew me before
I became most of me but like this guy
never you're gonna make it through
you're gonna be all right you're strong
you know you're an athlete and his
brother who actually was Muslim said you
know well if you don't make it man
that's probably what if you don't you
thinking about the other side yeah and
he said wow why is this person depressed
you know I mean drugs I mean other
things such as that [ __ ] should we
should be like healthy and healthy and
I'm saying everyone was like that but it
was definitely you know it was like it
was like this if this is it like this is
what people are looking for I know this
isn't for me
people Fame money access these types of
things full disclosure obviously before
I was Muslim I worked as a fashion model
I've been off of our families been off
of sugar for about six six plus going on
going on seven years now I don't get it
like this
[Music]
assalamu alaikum welcome to the deen
show i got special guests how you doing
are you sir how you doing [ __ ] feeling
blessed feeling blessed he just had some
good training huh I did I did yeah if
you you know man it was great it was
great as I said I tried to make up three
months in three hours so yeah you you've
uh you've been active in jiu-jitsu for
some time now I mean Matt Tom I would
say probably seven months yeah you know
but it's been something I've looked at
for awhile and I made up all kinds of
excuses not to explore it physically
like not to actually get in it but man
once I got in I'm kicking myself that I
didn't get in earlier but you're so
you're not only you're actually in your
mom right yeah I mean I was trained in
Damascus I served as an imam in New
Haven martial Islam I was the nah I was
the assistant Imam - your mom's a
tracker yeah for years and then he went
to Zaytuna then when he left Zaytuna i
became an imam of that community okay so
not not only that how long ago did you
accept Islam
1996 1996 yeah and you've also you've
been someone who's really into nutrition
yeah I think you know that's something
that you know started probably full
disclosure obviously before I was Muslim
I worked as a fashion model and that
really was the space I think I think I
like to think that I was eating healthy
you know before that during that time it
definitely got enhanced and then after
the conversion and I understood its
relationship to spirituality and other
aspects or and other things like this
and I really think that's when it took
to go took a hold you know in a whole
new understanding and in my life
they said fashion model how do how do
you make a switch from fashion model to
to uh being Muslim practicing Islam yeah
grace and mercy of Allah that's all I
can say you know it's it was you know
I'd known about Islam for some time my
cousin became Muslim in the 70s and he
just gave me some really
kind of how can I say some real subtle
but but kind of let me do my thing
without kind of you know forcing me or
making me feel bad about myself and just
kind of reserved me yeah and just kind
of observed and let that go and and you
18 years later I became Muslim so so
really it's grace and mercy of Allah but
also having people that allow you to
kind of unfortunately make your mistakes
you make them and and and they're there
to make go and guide you through that
talk to us what at what you you you you
must have been that what was your
mindset at that time that you started to
take the matter seriously you know I
think so obviously in modeling you're
seeing things that probably people would
be desirous of right people fame money
access these types of things so everyone
should be happy right yeah that if that
if the material if the material access
or you know access to to to to to
materialism on a man in a way that is
kind of unfettered you can just kind of
you know almost like snap your fingers
and people are jumping to fulfill your
you know commands your sorry your wishes
you think that you'd never be sad right
however that wasn't the case because I
feel that as human beings materialism
isn't the thing that that you know will
fill that void and also you know as as
you then begin to understand it through
religion that's a whole nother you know
I'm observing it just from it from like
not from a space of Islam obviously but
just like wow why is this person
depressed you know I mean drugs I mean
other things such as that [ __ ] should we
should be like healthy and healthy and
I'm saying everyone was like that but it
was definitely you know it was like it
was like this if this is it like this is
what people are looking for I know this
isn't for me
so I reminds me of the fashion designer
from Victoria's Secret he actually
jumped off you know the number one
capital suicide site in the world is
there in the Golden Gate Bridge and you
would think he's you know
he would also be somebody who's just got
the money that's getting paid and he
just dip off the bridge
yeah yeah and again I just I I think
that because there's an aspect of our
life that we're not fulfilling and you
know unfortunately it leads him and led
him to where where he was at and I but I
think that with that kind of that
self-reflection and that introspection
and having people around you that will
support you in those things right I
think that's also very important as well
to this concept of Safa in our tradition
of companionship
right of having people that can talk you
through those things that you're dealing
with but if everyone's on the same page
and everyone's kind of after this you
know next rung on the ladder and a
material understanding then hey you
didn't make it sorry for you you know
that mean I had an interesting
experience with two individuals one
individual he's he's a little bit older
he's a good friend of ours and he's in
the hospital
and he's supposed to have heart surgery
an amazing individual and while he's in
the hospital he's really reflecting now
his holding because he's gonna have open
he's gonna have heart surgery and
there's a there's a risk that he might
not make it it's a good chance it's
gonna be successful but there's a risk
there that it can go wrong so he's
staring somewhat subtly at death try and
he's seeing things differently said man
Eddie I'm just I'm at that point where
the smallest things you know I'm
preciate him now that's right right and
then there's another individual also
that now I had an experience to talk
with and this individual he's been
exposed to the truth he started he
started also like you started practicing
Islam but then he went away from it but
then now he's exploring all these other
options he's he's feeling anxiety he's
feeling like something's choking him but
he okay I said go ahead explore you know
if there's some chemical imbalance you
know go down that route that you know
seek medical advice attention but hold
on but the one who also created you why
not turn to him to help you but it seems
like that door now he's kind of closed I
don't know what happened in life but
he's chasing all other means not this
one right so just two different two
different people two different scenarios
once almost close to death scene
something totally different this other
one
what do you thought so many years yeah I
mean my my exactly I'm and I have a
similar story as well to a friend of
mine kind of ticked all the boxes you
know Ivy League education made it to
Wall Street was making a lot of money
doing well had a major health issue in
everyone it was interesting because
everyone was telling him like you're
gonna make it through you're gonna be
alright you're strong you know you're an
athlete and his brother who actually was
Muslim said you know weapon if you don't
make it man
that's probably what if you don't you're
thinking about the other side yeah and
he said literally it didn't matter how
many degrees and you know his brother
high school education and you know no
credential so maybe he's written off by
people but he just hit him with truth
man what if you don't make it you know I
mean and and there's this reality now
that's set in front of you of eternity
yeah and I think you know when when we
when we look for solutions to just make
our life better on this side then we'll
avoid those those the reflections of
this greater reality and I think that's
what we've become very good at as a
society unfortunately is that we push
out the reality that we are going to die
in that you know this thing is going to
come to an end and once that reality
I'll just be honest with you I mean I'm
like thirteen that concept would just
make me weep I would just it would
really concept of concept of like
eternity right eternal dust eternal like
whatever it was if you if I if I didn't
believe which I was I was I was raised
as a Catholic so I actually had this
concept of God in my life but this idea
of that it's gonna be eternal it's
either gonna be eternal dust that was
kind of scared to think about and then
like eternal damnation that was very
scary to think about or bliss so what
would you have to do mean God's pleasure
whatever we wanted to say so the
question was okay well well I don't
believe that we're just going to be dust
so that one was out right now between
these two what am I gonna do and I feel
like as you begin to to turn towards
this one then the then the earth then
the issues on this side become a lot
easier to deal with and they're put into
perspective now it doesn't have to get
to the point of where I need to have
open-heart surgery that's the hope right
like this phone calls are coming I call
them phone calls like God is calling you
all
the time Allah is is like sending you
messages and you're kind of like I'm not
ready for that one
but then it's like I can't avoid the
call you know I mean the phone call like
that the phone calls are coming in but
you're ignoring the silence but oh yeah
what do you like when you have an
opportunity what points do you like to
bring up to have someone reflect purpose
purpose of life yeah I think the first
one is like don't look at my life where
I'm at right now like you're seeing 23
years of practice right now right so
let's rewind that and start at point-a
right when I started I was getting high
and drinking and smoked and doing all
these things the day before I took my
Shahada and I give you knew me before I
became most of me but like this guy
never so you may be saying that to
yourself I can't do those things I
couldn't I was saying the same thing to
myself right up until I took my shot I
can't do those things man I think of it
I'm I'm in South Africa you know that
mean working in the fashion industry I'm
single man the world's open to me and
I'm thinking to myself like I'm gonna
give all this up mm-hmm
you didn't mean and and and so that's a
real conversation first and foremost
that and that's one of the things that I
feel that's the trick of shale pawn is
like he's gonna tell you all the things
that you're missing out so I'm gonna
tell you about the things are you gonna
gain right like sobriety debt-free you
know I mean these when you begin to put
these principles into your life I mean
come on right the average American I
think about living with eight or ten
thousand dollars of credit card debt now
you take on this Islamic principle of
not having interest-bearing loans and
other stuff like that
boom write that off that's done you know
I mean so now you begin to structure
your life in a way that puts things into
perspective the things that probably are
causing the anxiety that you're dealing
with right now and trying to get away
with so I think that's something where I
like to start with right now is it's
like one don't look at where I am right
now because this is like or whoever it
is whoever is practicing this or
whatever just think like where you are
right now but if you brought changes
into your life what type of positive
things would come into your life let's
just start there for a minute to see
what that conversation sounds like what
prompted you finally after how much time
did it take of an investigation looking
into Islam that it prompted you finally
to accept it this is the truth yeah well
you know what I think in my heart of
hearts I knew it
like I knew like I was young and it's a
trip because you know the whole kind of
social political reality that's that's
still happening in the Middle East was
happening that was happening in Iran
right so like my cousin is talking to me
about Islam it's the late 70s and
they're burning effigies of the
president it's Reagan at that time
they're burning the American flag and
you know and all these types of America
is the great shield pawn and blah blah
blah blah and all of that rhetoric and
people are simple that's Aslam right and
and now you know it's it's that's what
my family is kind of seeing and saying
well if that's what this thing is then I
don't want you moving towards that
direction yeah but in my heart of hearts
I'm like I'm thinking this is this is
true this man this is truth like I'm
doing my own exploration about prophets
I didn't aim a Salaam Allah bless all of
them and and I'm thinking to myself you
know this this this works out man like
the math works on this I mean about the
process on being the seal of seal of the
prophets and so you know I'm walking or
I'm actually walking around New York
City making la ilaha illaallah just
walking around saying that like it's
already on you telling my cousin yeah
cuz my cousin Todd he's like you know
this is there's this I'm going to teach
you this and my hope is that you'll not
leave this world except for that you
believe in this that's not Hillel law he
just you just can you were saying it I
was saying yeah and and in the midst of
all of that confusion in the midst of
all of the partying in the midst of all
of that crazy life like I'm actually
walking around New York saying this now
is just before you officially took your
show yeah yeah years before I mean I'm
talking this is yeah this is years
before yeah yeah
so then was a catalyst I mean this part
just saying this and now absolutely it
was it was putting light
yeah we're in South Africa we were
driving and I remember like like the
windshield wipers stopped working we
pulled a fuse out of like the cigarette
lighter put it in there it was this
really dense fall we were driving from
Cape Town to Johannesburg I mean it was
fog like I couldn't see you I couldn't
see the halfway down the hood of the car
the fog was that dense combined that now
without having any windshield wipers so
I'm in the car I'm driving for like two
hours in this
they I know that there's a ravine
because you drive on the on the opposite
side of the road in South Africa I know
there's a ravine on my left-hand side
and the whole time I'm driving light and
I know a lion the person next to me is
like what he's saying well what are you
saying I said I'm praying don't what it
will be okay yeah and HMDA leave that we
made it out and there was a horrific
accident like in front of us yeah
anybody can try right now at homeland I
hit a law it's like you're pretty much
obviously the standard translation is
nothing worthy of worship except the
Creator that's right but you're pretty
much saying I love you the most
that's right you know above everything
above the money above the car everything
I love you the most yeah one who created
me above and that's a beautiful way to
put it that's a really beautiful way to
put it because now it prioritizes things
I think that's the thing right now what
are our priorities the next iPhone the
next car the next you know whatever it
is the next laptop the next whatever it
is what's what's the priority like if
those are the things that were chasing
then trust me you're just a hamster on
the wheel man they got you you're just
going around in corner because it's
always gonna be the next best thing
now I'm not saying we don't look to have
those things in our lives but they're
not a priority they don't define who I
am I think that's what it is that I mean
yeah this is this is uh this is amazing
because this is what what we've seen
over the years talking with people is
that the simple message of Islam the
theology of Islam and the moral upright
message you know the call of just making
you the best human being that you can be
Islam has that blue Prayer
I love that idea of this whole thing to
me is making you a better version of
yourself date one day at a time you know
and I think that's it and that's the
other aspect that I wanted to say when
you asked me that question before about
talking to people is that's it we're not
looking for like you know just uproot
everything and I can be pretty traumatic
I so here's the story for you I mean - I
meet a brother I'm in South Africa so I
took my Shahada in South Africa and he
gives me a Quran and he's like you know
read this sir yeah seen and read this
sort smoked read yeah see when you get
up in the morning and read mock when you
go to bed at night and I and I promise
you that you'll see good in your life
you know so he
well this actually before him back it up
a little bit with me we drive a Joburg
we draw to Johannesburg we meet we have
coffee and he's like you know I'm a
mutual friend introduced us and it was
like you know what do you know about
what do you know about Islam and I was
like let you know muhammad rasool allah
and he's like you're Muslim and and I
was like you know I'm not he's like why
not said because I do all kinds of
things that Muslims you know don't do
yeah you know so he's like okay well
you're close to Islam
I mean to me that was because I wanted
to be Muslim you know I mean like I I
wanted that so that meant a lot now
here's the thing I made his brother and
his brother is like you know so I get to
Capetown I made his brother and his
brothers like Sonic Oh Mike I'm Salaam
how are you doing good he says you know
you know what do you do and it's at the
time so I'm working as a fashion model
he's like you have to quit your job and
I'm he's like oh where do you live I
said I rent a room in a house he the
women that lived there I said yeah there
are you know that goes to the whole
checklist then he's like you need to
move out you know you can go to a
mustard and stay in a must for three
days it'll be your right I'm not even
most fun I'm not even Muslim and he's
telling me you know trusting God he
brings up the whole Battle of Butler and
all of these things like this you know
and I'm thinking to myself man if I'm
not even Muslim and this is this I'm
like I'm like yeah okay waalaikumsalam
i never become a muslim so it's really
interesting how much weight not too much
man and just to I can make that upheaval
you know I mean like you know maybe this
is I'm coming out of like living in New
York and London in Paris and all this
other stuff and all of a sudden like
overnight like that I'm gonna you know
once they're put at one step at a time
you know let me allow people to have
their space to grow and now I'm not
saying that everything is you know
unicorns and butterflies and our Deen
has no parameters but I'm just saying at
least understand contextually who you're
dealing rather than try to put a cookie
cookie cutter on every single person
yeah yeah what would you say to convince
us so because this is uh this is
something that if you can convince
someone that
Prophet Muhammad was like Jesus Moses
Abraham and all the messengers that came
before him him just being the last and
final messenger and there's a there's a
ton of evidence there's a ton of proof
because obviously you don't just
surrender into this blindly I mean it's
based on evidence authenticity
everything is there that one needs to
know that indeed he's a messenger from
the Creator and he came with a message
that's clear it's believable and has a
ton of evidence what are a few things
that you like to mess that's share to
convince someone or have a plan of seed
to have someone really thinking to take
the matter serious that he is indeed who
he claimed he was mm-hmm
yeah well I think I think that one is
just you know if you are affirming the
logical I'm sorry the the chronological
order of prophets you know Allah be
pleased with all of them and you are
okay in each one of those transitions
what stopped you from examining this one
right is it a theological issue or is it
something else
and I think that's really the impasse
right now like I can accept a transition
and from Musa al-salaam
to eSATA Islam but for some reason from
a CA Salam to Muhammad's life so I'm
like I can't I couldn't accept that and
that's amoebic right I actually put the
onus back on used to say why mm-hmm why
right and it normally it comes down
there's some sort of information that
you've received that normally isn't
correct you know and and I think that
you know again if we get into you know
obviously we have dr. Ali Italia as a
tuna who's I mean have you seen his
Jesus in the in the Koran and other he
really his work is is is is incredible
on on Biblical technical texts and he
speaks Hebrew he speaks Greek he's
beginning and an Aramaic quite strong
meaning that he has access to the texts
and when you begin to get at these
things about Parakletos and you begin to
get about these to these things you know
it's affirmed in the Quran that recently
I was talking about a prophet that will
come after him and / Cletus has talked
about you know what I mean the
in in the book of forgive me it's one of
the Gospels yeah exactly
it's not the book of John I'm not sure
but don't quote me on that but but
anyway this mentioning here of you know
this you know messenger that will come
after me why and how our people not
allowed to actually examine that yeah so
to me here's the thing if I have truth
right I don't care what you want it come
bring everything man so so so I'm not
gonna hide things from you that means
you know what I'm not certain in my
truth so to me that's the question right
if we don't have access to this why not
right why not
so now we'll begin to have access to it
and I would say that's one thing but
also I would say look at the lifestyles
that people that are living I don't give
me some crazy like Isis blah blah blah
all this other nonsense man but look at
the people like in your neighborhood men
and look how they're there I mean you
know these types of things that
influence people to make just incredible
decisions taxi driver New York Times did
a story on him he returned bag that had
like ten thousand dollars in tax
remember that like Mercedes gave him a
Mercedes Benz because honesty and
integrity and these types of things that
they pride themselves on as a company to
me that that that reality that
translates from fourteen hundred and
thirty fourteen hundred forty years ago
into human beings right now I mean how
many other philosophies have existed and
we don't even see them around anymore
but two we don't see the type of
conviction that we have inside of that's
another aspect ask people to look at a
sponsor for that was Islam yeah exactly
that's from the teachings of it exactly
exactly I'm gonna get your reaction
we're gonna do a little reaction video
okay
well watch it okay see what what your
thoughts are okay
[Music]
[Music]
what are your first thoughts yeah I mean
well I did the context that I mean first
of all I'm thinking like what is it and
I'm hoping that it's like a mental
health issue right my first hope
secondly you know what I see there is is
his white supremacy right the things
that he said to him you're not a human
you know I mean this is stuff that I've
heard before to is then he uses religion
too then
to that firm what he's saying he's
hijacking now Christian exactly yeah
exactly and and you know it it's it's
really interesting just just just
watching that because I don't know what
what the context are those other people
Christian are they not Christian I don't
I don't know what that we don't know if
they're actually Muslim yeah exactly
but it doesn't seem like it's a Muslim
it's just a it's a black-white thing to
me that's what initially that's what I
that's what that's that's what I that's
what I think that's what I think and
that's what I see yeah yeah I start to
think my wheels start turning and I and
I think of Malcolm X when he wrote the
letter yeah and he said the truly I mean
without a doubt you know there's no
system out there that clearly you know
is so adamant about eliminating this
race problem like Islam yeah the
solution like he said yeah this is what
has me that goes through my mind ya know
it's interesting there's a pastor that
said the most segregated hour in in in
the country is church on Sundays you
know when services are happening because
every Koreans have their own churches
blacks have their own churches White's
have their own churches and so you know
this is something that I feel again like
it was interesting I saw something the
other day it said the it said the the
the the solution to fascism is education
and the solution to racism is travel hmm
right so I think that there's this idea
that if you're only around people like
you then yeah you're gonna you're gonna
you're gonna you're gonna think like
that so that's a beautiful thing like
when you go into our massage did I miss
everybody everybody call different all
different just in in Oakland it was like
a Burmese iftar a Vietnamese iftar a
Nigerian iftar a you know I mean
obviously there's the day center there
that happened I'm just saying maybe
there's like four or five different
ethnic
sponsoring an iftar inside of the must
[ __ ] right so now you know yeah it's
just it's just deep I mean I yes that I
don't know man that I am it's it's hard
even watching that it's kind of it makes
you feel uncomfortable yeah unlike oh
I'm uncomfortable I have about like but
it would bring this up because this is
the reality we're living in this is
what's really this is not one video
they're just popping up all over the
place
yeah and you know a lot of times you see
this hypocrisy where people they'll
point out this fringe element you know
then same state and I'll try to make
Muslims look like you know yeah
violent and barbaric even though the
data shows and statistically this is
there is a professor Stanley fish I
think his name is he's right next to
where we are there's a tuna he wrote an
entire book on that are Muslims more
violent I think it was called and then
he flattened flattened they argument I
got that I got that statistic of more
Muslims less murder that statistic over
a hundred thousand that's right per
capita and it comes down to like 2.7
percent Muslim majority countries as
opposed to you know here you have it's
like three times more murder right so
they flipped us but now I'm seeing this
is like the this is like the the white
and when I say why I mean I'm white I'm
Muslim it doesn't matter you know give
me Italian polish whatever it is but
people like this ladies truly following
the I think of something that's
connected to Jesus where one came to
Jesus said and it was the Gospel of
Matthew said oh good master well the
good thing can I do that I may have
eternal life and Jesus says why are you
calling me good there's none good but
God right and then he said if one wants
to enter to Paradise Jenna you know
today he said one keeps most keep the
commandments then he goes on he said
what are they said you know thou shalt
not commit adultery bear false witness
and the list goes on of same thing
that's in Islam but then he said he said
and love your neighbor like you love
yourself look at that so if you're a
true Christian and we want people to be
really proud you're gonna be a Christian
be a true Christian right and because
this is not a true Christian right so
there's a new true human being you so
this is like that white I this is
white Christian Isis that worst yes
Garrett you're starting to see more of
this come come up yeah yeah yeah no it's
it's really interesting it's really like
you said I'm not I'm not
like I said uncomfortable in that the
term that's being flown all the way now
I go I'm uncomfortable no I like like
first of all I'm thinking like you know
how's my man gonna respond you know and
he's responding like a Christian he's on
some like turned the other cheek
he's doing it he's doing it so it's
really interesting here you're seeing
that he's claiming and he's acting yeah
so we can make all the claims that we
want live it man yeah live it have you
have you have you seen because I mean
the data shows you have Islamophobia is
like you know now these Dave again with
the with the amount of attacks now on
mush kids on Muslims you know it's like
5% a 500% increase I think just recently
they had an article of how many Muslims
have been attacked and that how have you
guys there in California and Tabarrok
law from the grace and mercy of Allah we
we haven't experienced that you know I
think there's this kind of live and let
live and tolerate you kind of leftist
Berkeley progressive and that's where we
that's where we are you know and and I
think you know well I just say you know
how many lovely you know there have
there were some some instances on campus
you know didn't mean but again it sounds
like me and I'm trying to write them off
but it did sound like they were kind of
some mental health issues but I mean
definitely there are you know obviously
you had this Milo Milo Yan Annapolis who
was you know fighting to come to campus
and talk his talk big yeah yeah that
whole Breitbart crew you know and and
you know so you actually had that but
again you know I see this as I see these
guys as opportunists to be honest with
you yeah it's just a new way to make my
own Pam Geller is making you know what
is it a hundred and twenty thousand off
of a blog or something like this big
business now something businessmen and
it's and for those who apostate from
Islam it's big business man yeah you
know and and and
and everything tanks looking to grab you
up and long as you've got the story that
I were and then and then come to find
out what are their families say dude was
never in Hamas dude he didn't even pray
he was like a secular Muslim who had no
connection to lead Shabbat or something
like that whatever his name is I know
you can Google one of these guys that
that pop up and then take him as if he
he's advising Ray Kelly like the New
York you know Police Commissioner and
these types of things when you dig and
do your due diligence on these
individuals that's the scary thing that
they don't bring in someone like you
they don't bring in someone like you
know a representative from you know the
the Muslim community a scholar or
someone who is gonna come in and teach
law enforcement they have some of these
they've this is a scary thing and many
of the law enforcement agencies they
have a lot of these Islamophobes
teaching their classes yeah that's very
yeah yeah exactly and I think and I
think so at that point then you're not
looking for a solution yeah get in I
mean and and because then you've put in
everyone's in the minds of these cadets
or whoever they are that that everyone
that that that everyone's a potential
threat yes everyone's a potential threat
who's a Muslim and it was really
interesting I was I was I was looking
the other day I was reading something on
the plane the other day and it was
talking about how even just the West has
shifted in its in its kind of you know
the hijab was kind of like this like the
idea of the harem and it was exotic and
they sexualized it and you know that's
how it was kind of portrayed now it's
like you know what I mean this it's it's
it's a it's seen as like leaning towards
violence and anybody jump that yeah that
would put because a woman because of
this whole idea about conviction yeah as
you become more religious right
religiosity brie it brings you to this
place of violence but I'm like no that's
so insane that's insane I can bring you
I mean I just like I said I lived about
ten years in the Middle East my
experience has been completely opposite
of that and that's just that's traveling
through the Middle East not just in one
country or one group of people yeah but
I see that that's a lack of knowledge of
like this mad person a little
knowledge of Christianity that's right
and now what happens right that's right
he's becomes a zealot he becomes a
fanatic and extremists made a little bit
of knowledge of Islam
right but probably more turn into
extremists with you know all of the
violence that's happening in his in our
own country but more Islam helps to
humble you to become a better human
being the best version of yourself that
you were saying a hundred percent and I
mean that's the whole thing to this
whole argument about you know killing
the non-muslims and both I mean what I'm
gonna take Shahada and like go kill my
family right from like like that's my
duty now as a Muslim is this insane like
that you it's insane that you'd actually
believe that but that's the that's
exactly what it's in it's insane that
you would actually believe that I want
to show since you brought up the hijab
this is uh let me get your your reaction
to this one since you mentioned the
hijab so this is a popular someone share
this with me and let's see what you
think about this stays true to her
signature style and reveals why she
keeps her body covered up I never want
the world to know everything about me I
mean that's why I wear big baggy clothes
nobody can have an opinion because they
haven't seen what's underneath you know
nobody can be like oh she's she's slim
thick she's not slim thick she's she got
a flap she's got a fat no one can say
any of that because they don't know I
love that Billie is seriously just
breaking the mold and doing it her own
way she wants people to focus on the
fashion and not her figure how in
general would you describe your style I
want to see heads look up smile has
always been something I care about
you're talking about his yeah not
totally hit but yeah yeah what I mean if
you think about the meaning of the head
job I like to cover something then yeah
I mean I mean you know it does yeah it
just seems like you know many people
that's why it's so important our
education because it seems like the
fitrah the the natural state of the
human being I mean gets corrupted the
environment you know our surroundings
but it's just inside of us and you just
need once Islam comes it fits like a
glove now it gives you that blueprint
you know that's right so you can see her
kind of going toward that she don't want
people to measure her by her body but by
her and tell her that's right she's
doing something a little above and
beyond what everybody's doing
yeah and it's but it's interesting
though of how someone like that is is is
applauded and and praised for it but
yeah how many Muslim women are doing
this every day
and would probably say you know seventy
percent or whatever obviously it's for a
law and it's in following a commandment
like this but what actually say those
same things as well - I'm not interested
in you observing me in a way that I
don't want to be to observe by you so
bill eh she's like have you ever heard
of RIT no no she's like the new thing
now okay so they knew Britney Spears yes
Billie Asia I guess she's real popular
so now she's like you just said it's
like she wants to cover up show less
wearing baggy clothes yeah yes pretty
much
that's is Lomb not revealing the shape
of hijab not revealing the shape of your
your body but on top of that having been
just a good human being good moral
character and whatnot who now you said
if as soon as if she would have said
Islam Muslim they shot that exactly
right they didn't look in the comment
section when Lindsay Lohan or whatever
and
took Shahada hey she's suffering from
mental illness always other things when
she came on and said I'm covering my
body because you know it's just it's
just wow like basically wow you can be
liberated but on our Terms not Islam
yeah exactly you have to be liberate on
our terms and we'll determine what
liberation looks like chakra see exactly
exactly but the beautiful thing about
though is that people aren't stupid yes
people are not stupid you know the mean
and and and you know you can have she
comes and says you can have your own
opinions but you're not entitled to your
own facts
you can have your own opinions but have
opinions but you know to your own facts
so she's telling you you didn't mean
this fact about me we can form any
opinion we want that fact remains with
her the fact of what Muslims are doing
you can have your opinion all day the
fact will remain the fact you know you
had this whole you have the the me to
movement and when I recently we were
talking about it this is this is another
point like that Islam has all these
solutions and now many of these big
corporate giants and whatnot now they're
implementing which you would think like
wow this is what Islam says yeah you
know how to interact with the opposite
gender what's right for the protection
of the woman and yeah and now they're
actually implementing these ends but
it's interesting how it has to run this
whole cycle and go through being called
patriarchal and all these other things
but the end of the day you're going to
come to the same conclusion right and so
but again it's on our terms yes I think
it is and I think to me that's a rager
problem like I I'm not you know like I
don't think I don't know it's just I was
talking to a student the other day about
this idea of what is it like is is the
issue like a theological issue or is the
issue one of like autonomy because think
in the in the United States of course
like this whole idea about you know
freedom and liberty and and
individualism and I think now if one
affirms that there's a god now sudden I
have to be like bound to those rules
like I'm no longer like the top of the
chain like the top of the pyramid so to
speak right there's someone that I have
to and I think that's it that that
becomes a problem for for for for people
one of the people that I benefit you
know and this doesn't take anything away
from him you know Tony Robbins right he
got caught up in this scandal also
I don't I don't really I mean there's
different levels to this in Islam is
just another level so obviously and I
think I mean any man you cannot just
this is the nature of man you know
someone who is who is at his level just
like you you were at in a different
world
you're still he's a good I mean he's
driving to educate people and he has
really some some good some good things
in place that that if you implement it
can it can help you get to another level
Islam just takes you to the whole you
know yeah the top of the levels but what
happened with with Tony was again now
imagine if you're in this situation
you're probably doing the same thing you
know he's calling out the mo he's got
the most beautiful women there he's
calling the most beautiful women to be
with him this is the nature of man I
mean what do you expect from that you
know but the hypocrisy of society now
they want to like like my take him under
a microscope and just dismantle him and
what now
and I'm like Tony look Islam has the
solutions you want more you can get an
extra family it just tells you don't be
alone you know with the opposite gender
because there's a chemistry there that
there's a wise saying that I'd rather be
alone wise men said I'd rather be alone
with a suitcase of money than a
beautiful woman and the proof is
actually in the Quran you know the
creator is telling us that's right you
know the thing that that excites man the
most yeah what do you think about it
well I don't know I think I think I
think there's been such a deconstruction
on so many levels we're talking about
the deconstruction of of gender now you
know now you said like a man's design
that becomes a problem you can say that
now maybe even just man you can't say
that either that's a problematic so then
you have this idea of like you're
liberated once you fulfill your desires
be you you don't know I mean and I think
this is do you whatever that you know
people say but to me that's what leads
to the type of collapse really I feel
like the collapse that we're seeing
right now we've never seen a level of
mental health and suicide and of the
numbers that we're seeing right now and
I'm sorry I think that what happens
that once you set someone on a path that
that that can never be fulfilled right
it's the moving on to the next thing the
next thing the next thing so if you get
to that continuing well I've done this
I've done this I've done this I what's
left yeah well what what if all of this
is leaving me empty then what's a sense
and purpose of living yeah right and I
think that's where these ideas are
coming into you know of questioning
existence at that point and we're like
yeah if you have no telly oh so if there
is no kind of end to this thing then
yeah just keep just keep you know being
a consumer in a world that is set up for
financial gain and to keep you a
consumer and I think to me that's why
you see why the Malcolm's and why the
doctor kings and why others were such a
problem because they're speaking against
that narrative you know obviously race
is the context that it's said in but if
you look at dr. King's work at the end
what he's talking about you know the big
three where he talks about you know
incarceration and war and then and and
racism you know that's that's you know
another area that we don't want to talk
about you know the military-industrial
complex and other things such as this
yeah how long have you been into eating
the from when you became Muslim
practicing Islam were you always well
obviously yeah you had to stay fit so
you were you eating tell you about back
then before being a slot no I you know I
I wasn't I think I've always I you know
we grew up on processed foods you know
and but I never liked it you know I know
nothing against my mother obviously
she's a great cook but would like these
like soggy like string beans because
they've been in a can and I mean I just
you know that whole transition that
happens from like the post-war you know
industrialization of food to for shelf
life's and now we're being fed those
same types of things like I'm not I'm
not interested in that and so I think
what happens with this shift is that you
know you just have this this idea not
only does it not
tastes good but you like tolerate it not
tasting good but now when you begin to
kind of look at like nutritional value
and how then that relates to like output
like what you can do either on a
physical level or like on a cognitive
level like once you begin to cross that
you're like oh no this I'm not going you
know that I mean I I and here's a thing
for me the thing that really turned the
corner for me was like it wasn't about
law it wasn't about you know was about
is about love mmm how much do I love my
children mm-hmm and will I express my
love in this way and that's really the
thing that like the lights went on yeah
so that was you're actually at another
level you actually hunt your hunt for
your own food and yeah I mean I'm not a
sudden hunter that sentence is defined
by someone who only eats what they hunt
yeah so I'm not on that level but for me
you know I I just got tired of like
people complaining all the time of how
bad the halal meat is at the markets
right yeah I get it like you know I mean
it's pretty horrific I wrote my graduate
thesis on this I know what I know kind
of what we're talking about I've seen it
I've seen it in Mecca we wait what are
we talking about what yeah exactly so I
got I got I got to this point where I'm
like I'm just tired of people
complaining so that's why I started that
hashtag get your own halal
get your own hello right so you go out
and get it then right good and if you
can't hunt okay that's one level go make
a relationship with a farm man go make a
relationship with a farmer how about
that
how about he's introduced now to the
beautiful manner in which we you know
harvest a animal how we slaughter an
animal right and then all then you begin
to learn the prophetic ethics that are
concerned with the humane taking of this
animal's life and then the next level on
that is how you honor that animal
through the energy that you will use to
do things so work righteousness do that
meat now you've honored that animal work
things that are displeasing to the
Creator you've dishonored that animal
and but but so yeah to get to that point
you know when we look at this you know
the Sharia sets a pretty low standard in
terms of
Hilal like like legally you basically
have to have three things you have to
have the the the tool in which you are
using to slaughter the manner in which a
person slaughters and then you know and
then really the religious status of the
person slaughtering if you meet those
three things lots of things halal and I
think that's where we're at right now
because we've become a hyper legalized
community and we've removed the ethics
because it complicates things or it
makes things difficult or you know I
mean the Deen is easy okay yeah the Deen
is easy but you're eating something
that's pumped with hormones you know
antibiotics all these other things
abused physically abused and just
because you said bismillah when you cut
the neck of it now a sudden it's
supposed to you know fulfill the highest
standard of it no I'm sorry it doesn't
matter it completes the law you know the
min but in terms of these higher
standards of what people and then that's
when you get this idea but well can I
eat non-halal on me but at least it's
it's it's the it's grass-fed it's humane
it's being good I can't find anything in
our tradition that was gonna say to you
that legally you can eat meat that did
not meet the conditions for hell out or
was from people of the book I think a
lot of people they don't understand and
much talk and importance is not giving
in distinguishing okay you have halau
yeah now tell you about like yet
coca-cola might be hello you can drink
it but it's not tell you about yeah
people don't know the difference right
and I think you know the interesting
thing here is that there's one level
just for the you know what what it does
to your body that's one level but I
think what the pulse is Lomb as you
begin to read into it more his concern
extends also to to the animal like as a
hadith that said you know he walked by
an animal that was very thin you could
like to see its ribs and it's a backbone
and like this and he said ride them when
they're healthy and slaughter them when
they're healthy right so now you know in
Prophet Muhammad
teaching right and so you have now
consideration III think brother I think
it goes all the way out to like here's
the thing no will argue that
strawberries are like halal Haram memos
that you're crazy right but now if you
want to talk about ty Yuba and you
didn't take into consideration like okay
why is it that there's a higher
percentage of cancer and people who are
picking the strawberries because of the
the the the art the carcinogenic s--
that are inside of the pesticides that
are being used and those people are not
allowed to have access to health care
like other people are and their children
are allowed to have edgy excessed to
education another because they're
undocumented workers and they're picking
our strawberries as a Muslim who's gonna
be rah rah rah social justice rah rah
rah black lives matter rah rah rah on my
social justice bandwagon but yeah I
won't look at food my intake on that I'm
sorry man you've missed the point you've
missed the point you've made it very
convenient for yourself right in certain
areas and you're dismissing certain
areas that are very clear and I think as
we begin to adopt that as a community
now we've begin to kind of be more
comprehensive in our deen right because
at the end of the end of the day what
I'm finding over and over again brother
is we're only concerned with like money
like how much does it cost
yeah it cost less cool I'll take it go
back with why what's going on with the
strawberries no don't be saying so so so
you have actually happens actually
happening yeah yeah
like tomato Immokalee Florida like most
of our Tomatoes come from yeah they're
picked by undocumented workers yeah they
don't have access to health care their
children don't have access to education
in the way that they should right but as
Muslims
we're not even taking that into
consideration we're just like kalasa
give me that give me the food so what
I'm saying in terms of tight you if
we're talking about being ethical
consumers we're looking at this thing
all the way up and we're supporting the
companies that are doing it right and
we're not supporting and putting our
dollars behind companies and they're not
doing it right to me that's that's
really how this thing you know plays out
so yeah when you're spraying roundup in
your spray these chemicals Monsanto so
give me a break man then it just change
it to bear and they're also
you met you mentioned some last time we
spoke you mentioned how when the Creator
God Almighty Allah when when he when he
made something it's in a fine-tuning as
soon as you you you you add or delete
you you take it out of its uh you know
precision mm-hmm remember what you told
me yeah a little bit but I think that
remind me again is exactly what I mean
because I'm a parent paraphrase you were
talking about when the crater when a law
when he creates something you know I
mean yeah and this was relating back to
GMO changing the creation of God yeah
yeah that's right
yeah the verse where you read a New York
later in a hunka law you know I mean
that they are desires to change the
creation of a laws there's a verse
that's in the Quran and it's it's
connected to something else however you
could make an analogy and now I guess
class it's called right in in in terms
of this of the law but but you know I
think because here's the thing you know
all of these promises that were made to
the Indians I mean you know about this
you know these these GMO crops that were
supposed to be super crops and all these
other things but well they didn't tell
them was how much water it would take
for example right so now they can't pay
for the amount of water that's required
for for irrigation of these plants so
the other crops die and you don't have
access to the seeds now they're out
there in debt and they're actually
there's suicide that's happening there's
a drinking you know the things that they
should be spraying on their plants and
all this other stuff as a result because
of the debt that they've incurred and
other things such as this so it's a
vicious cycle and I think that you know
when you look at permaculture when you
look at you know these types of
approaches what Bill Mollison is is is
you know Geoff Lawton contemporary David
hungry and others such as this are
promoting and the work that they're
doing I mean Jeff is being brought into
to a lot of these refugee camps in other
places and bringing in these structures
that work with nature rather than
against it so that's how I see it's like
to two different approaches like you
said earlier in the talk when we're
talking right you have this one that's
like working with a harmony of nature go
and look at what does the decomposition
look like when a tree falls and how do
things grow out of it and things like
there's a natural order that's happening
then we come in we're saying like no
because we need the crop to yield this
much we want to now contain all of the
variables and eliminate all the
variables actually right and in the
process now we are disrupting in my
opinion this cycle that God has has has
created for this and then we're seeing
we're seeing the price the people are
paying the price for it
what do you think there's a there's a
lot of good holistic doctors you know a
lot of papers have been written on this
but it kind of goes against the
mainstream it goes against big industry
money and they talk about you know the
power of food many have got one comes to
mind dr. Kelly Brogan she writes
extensively on this healing people
through nutrition through food she also
writes about how many of these
medications are creating mental illness
creating people that are out there
gunning people down linking it back to
the prescription drugs and mental health
issues coming back to to this what we're
talking about you know ya know I mean
well this being connected somehow here's
the thing
well this is the thing that I looked at
one time if you take a pill like what's
the path goes in goes into your stomach
and then what happens it finds its way
into your bloodstream right food is the
same thing so there did the same paths
so why is it that this synthetic pill
can do what you know foods or herbs or
other things I mean are we are we at a
point in a society where we are seeing
things in dealing with things that other
that other Jenner that other societies
didn't have to deal with and if they
were dealing with them in a way that
that was using you know now I'm not
writing off completely allopathic
medicine there are there are some
benefits hundred-percent
yeah but also I'm not wholeheartedly
taking it all in and saying it has the
answer for everything I feel that in
both of them is good however what I will
say is that I'm looking to find out
where these we're here's the other thing
I think it's two things one is that that
that's that path when I talk about the
second one is I feel that if a law if
Almighty God is is is is about mercy
then he's gonna put his mercy in
in cures that are accessible to
everybody everybody and not just people
on a certain socio-economic path and
this is I'll tell you what I was taking
uh X is a wilderness survival course I
was in Maine I took this course and
poison ivy grows right next to its
antidote which is called jewelweed they
grow physically they go right next to
each other and and but the thing is you
have to actually put the jewelweed on
before the the poison ivy hit you can't
put it on after now here's the thing I
actually had a medical student I told
him that they were kind of like I don't
know if I really believe you but my
Muslim you know they ran tests on their
arm 100% this arm swelled up inflamed
this arm absolutely not so not I tested
it they tested it right first now here's
the thing when our instructor was
telling us about that they grow right
next to each other I thought about this
hadith polis on my buns ilaha illah be
Dola Allah doesn't send down a malady
except for with its cure now here's the
thing the BA here Allah be de wha this
BA in Arabic is called the bat of
Messiah right literally the companion so
it seemed like right where the properly
some say if a fly falls into your soup
but I get both wings in because in one
side is the is the is the toxin and the
other side is the cure
so here that's my thought right Allah
sends down this thing right next to it
it's gonna be its cure yes and we're
looking for all of these other places
and and and I'd love to see Muslims
research in these areas based off of
these you know the main concepts that
exists inside of our tradition but this
is the thing if where people have sinned
another way we we have to have an open
mind and we have to because nowadays
that they act as this curriculum came
down from the divine and you know you
probably talked to a lot of doctors they
don't learn nutrition in medical school
like just the driver that drove me over
here today not driver how many like
someone from the community he's a
medical student actually used the last
time I was here I stayed with him and he
we had this exact conversation because
he's on the same page about this he's
like look I'm in medical school and most
of the students that I'm talking about
about this gut-brain relationship as dr.
Natasha
Kamel McBride talks about called gaps
got in psychology syndromes relationship
doctor you know Gundry is talking about
Steven Gundry is talking about it now I
just a Muslim doctor on an Instagram
just hit me up the other day he goes by
the name of the gut MD so he saw some of
the stuff that I've been putting up you
know he said no one it's like it's like
I'm like they're hearing Greek for the
first time we're all medical students
Yeah right he's in his rotations right
now he's saying none of them have heard
of this relationship before of the gut
and and and psychology but like you said
this thing is sent out my wife my wife
is my wife is trained nine years in
Damascus as a student of knowledge but
now she is
she taught at Zaytuna for years but now
she's a full-time student as a midwife
yeah and the same thing you know she met
a woman who's a physician who literally
like berated her man I mean like wife
was like wife was so hurt because of you
know the dangers of home birth are you
kidding me so everyone in civilization
up until when you came on the scene was
wrong and now because your statistics in
your data will tell us that you can
infant mortality rates are down and this
that and the third like all the sudden
we're just supposed to like give
ourselves up at the altar to this and
and relinquish all the things that
society has been doing up until up until
this point are you kidding me you would
talk about humility man how about you
show some humility just because you've
been credencial eyes doesn't mean that
you have all of the answers my friend
and I think that's what you said about
having an open mind I think especially
as a Muslim this was a Muslim doctor she
was talking to her man broke her heart
broke her heart and he's are the same
people that you go and you know and and
you're sitting around you got I mean
it's not to put Donnie doctors there's
got to be you got to rise to the next
level there's so much to learn you know
what I mean take the good from the
allopathic go out there and take the
good from Chinese medicine the Sunnah
that's right and be the best Oh Donnie
the Greek tradition oh yeah
the they call him the father of medicine
what's his name on better ways what's
his name Hippocrates yes he said let
food be your medicine medicine be your
food and he prepared I think oath do no
harm but man if you look at you know a
table full of doctors and some moistures
there sit around you know drinking
coca-cola Pepsi yes yeah yeah
heating the fake food yeah and now this
is the person that is is what is he's
been trained to be you know we know what
MD stands for
master drug dealer so he's just pushing
the drugs you know I mean it's wild you
know I went to I went I don't know for a
checkup or something like I can't
remember and I don't to be full
transparency I don't really go to the
house often you know this is what woke
me up when I start with the most healthy
walking people and I asked them when's
the last time your doctor I thought this
is just 20 years ago and what do you do
i watch what I eat I take care of myself
when I got my job at Dartmouth this was
2000 and this was 2010 the fall of 2010
I went to get my checkup HR it sends you
there you have to go get a medical
checkup the doctor comes back and says
I'm missing can I ask your questions
yeah so your medical records show the
last time we're at the doc was 15 years
ago
oh yeah and I said yeah sounds about
right there just got a blank stare you
know and I can say that was that was
2010 we're at 9 I saw another nine years
honestly I've probably been to a doctor
you know I mean like having to go to one
yeah I thought I broke my toe and to get
my meniscus I tore my meniscus there's
certain pages yeah that's where it in
terms of just the best yeah going
because I thought it was sick I don't
know that I've been the last nine years
and so what I was going to say is that
the one time that I went in to go get
some blood drawn what it was man line up
at the pharmacy downstairs was just I
mean just cast in white coats I just
think like this is like wookie rayray
like a little man
it's insane CBC's popping up all over
the place everywhere
legalized drug pushing yeah
clocking my $2.00 on the first and 15 I
mean this is so it comes down if we can
get people what advice would you have
you was real simple I mean eating the
tiny bat that the craters given avoiding
fake food eating real food obviously if
there's you know emergency situation you
got to get there but people just
differentiating I mean between the two
because you're not going to go to the to
the regular doctor and he's going to
tell you you know give you a
prescription on changing some of the the
things in your cupboard and yeah
removing things from your fridge he's
not no because he's not trained there
yeah and I'm sorry but like the like
that things are connected right okay so
here's the thing check this out
lifestyle right so lifestyle one but to
just even physically yeah so oh I've got
a pain in my knee
well here's take these right no one's
telling you that maybe like your your
your spine is misaligned which cause
your shoulders to be misaligned which
cause your hip to be misaligned which
now cause you need to be misaligned so
all every single step you're taking it's
like if it's supposed to work like this
and the joint is just skewed a bit now
how many steps are you taking it's
grinding in the wrong place you're gonna
have a hip pain but no one's telling you
that's because I'm gonna need paint
problem but no one's telling you that
your pelvis is tilted and no one is
telling you that's because your
shoulders are misaligned and I was
telling you that because your spines
misaligned
so now sudden you begin to like look at
chiropractic you begin to look at
acupuncture begin to look at you know
Yoga you begin to look at steam baths
you know heat getting into heat in the
ice and and so to me the biggest thing I
think right now is this whole issue of
prolonged inflammation when you mention
these things they'll say that okay this
is unscientific this is more quackery
what would you say that's our proof is
in the pudding yeah well you flipped
that but a lot of this stuff that is
there there's no science behind much of
the things that are going on nowadays
okay I mean yeah you know and there's an
over the hundred years there's nothing
actually been cured but I think it's
confirmation bias you know I mean I'm
sorry like I think when you have you
know you're the malpractice insurance is
so high then there's a number that you
have to meet per day and this is from
someone who
left the practice so this is the the kid
I can't I can't take care of patients in
this way basically and she was like I'm
I'm done
you know that means she had her own
practice with with someone else and just
said you know the pace that I'm bound to
because of because of our malpractice
insurance and those numbers basically I
think what it is is like seven minutes
or something like that then she was I
think she said it was like you had seven
minutes to diagnose with a patient like
the full like for the minute you walk in
the door you have seven minutes yeah
so the hi how are you do like all that
stuff you know I mean that's eating
that's eating time you can tell by a
good doctor the amount of time they
spent on the initial visit I mean a good
doctor Marie last time when they spent
like an hour and a half at least minimum
this is more of a doctor that's holistic
minded yeah it was really looking off to
manage the symptom but looking for the
for the root problem I mean just a
classic example like one of these things
that they're talking about you know how
like if you don't have the right type of
sleep that it can affect your blood
pressure yeah but if I just come in and
be like oh well you've got high blood
pressure never ask you about your
sleeping patterns right I'm just gonna
issue you a pill now yeah you know I
mean and as I'm saying about looking at
holistically like you talked to me what
is it I you didn't mean and yeah there's
a checklist do you smoke do you have
diabetes in your family do you have that
like okay but you know I mean I just
think that there's other factors that
are not captured in that that you know
what I mean
that is really interesting friend told
me this and I didn't confirm it but I
think it's just an interesting concept
whether it's true or it's not he said
that there was a time in Chinese
medicine where you mentioned this to me
yeah where you paid your doctor right
when you were healthy and you didn't pay
him when you were or her you didn't pay
the doctor when you were when you were
sick right now think about that if the
whole health care project is predicated
upon keeping people healthy what greater
motivator is it then that you don't get
paid if I'm sick man yeah
it's powerful it's really powerful that
amazing so Wow we covered a lot this is
uh because those are the key components
I mean have a healthy heart you know
life is all comes back to lifestyle
that's right and food tell you about you
know eating the good food that the
Creator law has given us and many of
these other things these are components
and if you miss one and which many
people are missing two three of them for
and EMS yeah we're in mashaallah people
can benefit some of these some of these
advices and I try to push out there what
we started with and you could do it - we
started with let you know him the law
and one can start saying it this is
putting God Almighty Allah above
everyone in anything and you were saying
it you know hey look house simplest like
a little about it
I said hey la la la la hey la la and
then we talked about the importance of
eating real food
there's halau and there's type type is
the real how would you define that tie
you back yeah it is a tough word to to
to to define but you know like say
really food yeah yeah yeah pure here
where is it pure organic yeah yeah yeah
and yeah I mean I think I think it's
probably closer akin to what we find now
of the organic for you know mean humane
antibiotic free hormone free it just
they didn't have to say all those things
because that was the normal the norm
that was the norm yeah now we've
industrialized it yeah and now we have
to call it real food I mean that does
that and of itself is insane yeah right
when you want to eat real food
does it make sense yeah Wow and then uh
and then so in trying to give advice to
the must use to get the coca-cola out of
the must use that's right percent it
really actually that's the other stop
giving kids these candies yeah you
exactly give them like some some dates
apricot exactly always just say you know
dried mangoes you know me just begin to
explore yeah begin to explore and then
you know just the the brother has heard
that dropped me off you know he was
talking but he said they went to Soho
this morning at the Masjid and again not
pounding on must is where he was like
look they gave us like a new a big thing
of Nutella and and some cereal
some like you know some sort of like you
know lucky charm I mean not like I was a
bit lucky fruit loops or something like
this and then that was like the like
curry chicken lamb dishes that like I
mean it's about a lot like we've
experimented this year had a green
smoothie every morning man
that's it that's it so horizontally and
I'm not just like sitting around doing
nothing but day's pretty active and and
and and when I get you through huh yeah
yeah yeah and then break it with celery
juice we do we do celery juice and then
we have a very simple meal of a protein
a salad and a vegetable no it's like a
steamed broccoli or a steamed
cauliflower or a big sweet potato or
something like that and then a salad
very simple salad and you're good man
and we've been the whole month the whole
month like that equals tell you bout
equals tell you about and this is an act
of Ibadan now yeah you get rewarded for
that because your intention is to honor
your body that's right you're developing
nutritional integrity honoring this
vehicle yeah is getting you through life
you can get reward if I love that term
nutritional integrity this is from my my
nutrition is Jim Marlow lash out yeah so
this is I mean this is just so important
and inshallah this can be a benefit to
people because the results are
devastating cancer heart disease all
this stems from doing the opposite what
Allah told us eating the garbage fake
foods yeah yeah and those are just
interesting those cereals that you
mentioned they did they did studies that
glyphosate was in the majority of these
major brand cereals and this is one a
leader that's connected to cancer so
you're giving your kids cancer food
that's why I said what I said what why I
said what I said it stems from love now
how can you okay even eat with a smoke
there's fire so say it's not to that
degree that it's cancer-causing but it's
something else why would you even think
about serving that to your child it
wouldn't he I mean if I told you that
this is gonna us being some sort of harm
to your child you'd be like I know
they'd be like get that thing away from
me we're like to food though bring it
bring give me give me give me a six pack
of it you know parents are
this is like a form of child abuse I'm
sorry to use such strong language but
you see parents projecting their food
preferences on these kids you see these
kids over beasts have you look at the
parent there they're right there with
the kids so they're the ones yeah and
abusing their kids in this way you know
yeah and I think the thing is is it's
also convenience like I get it and I'm
not trying to knock people or shame here
was another term that we say today but
however we have to slow down then you
didn't mean if that's what it is like if
it's just a microwave meal I'm gonna pop
it in like that then other things are
wrong in my life that I need to address
as to why I only have time to pop a
microwave meal and give that to my child
like you know and then and it's
interesting because people who ask us
like you know oh my god your kids eat
Brussels sprouts and asparagus and
artichoke hearts and broccoli and all of
those things you know why because we
didn't give them those other things in
the beginning and so now it's like
someone came to my house or like all my
kid will only eat mac and cheese but if
you only gave them mac and cheese what
do you think now I'm certain they're
gonna switch to Brussels sprouts you've
got them addicted to the fake foods to
sugar and you made them a sugar out of
yeah yeah because it's pumped in all
these foods and that's that you know
it's really a trip is that those are the
two things the body into this whole
sweet and savory you know I mean the
glucose and sodium like those are the
things that our bodies crave yeah and so
they're not stupid you know I mean and
that's why I like the milkshake and the
sodas are the sugars and then also their
sugar in the ketchup and the sugar and
the bread and sugar in the and then the
salty is like the fake meat in the
McDonald's they're not I mean this is
not this is not rocket science and then
you go to you're sorry to bring up the
doctor at the analogy again but you go
to your average doctor he says don't
worry about it because he's eating the
same thing bell teeth all right so let's
close it up we're gonna have to do this
again
Emerson I look forward to very
enlightening and so many different gems
here so thank you very much I really
appreciate it what cause what else what
would you do a simple place to start
with this you know for the person who's
seeking purpose now they heard this and
also linking it back what final words of
closing also for the person there's all
these diets all these trends and
someone's really they tried this and
that they just you know I like I like to
tell
people eat real food avoid fake food
that's white belt level yeah right yeah
what do you like to tell me yeah I would
say that you know one is you know if you
if you get subbed right there's another
match so I've met with people and they
get all set up and they do all these
things but then they're like hey I
didn't hear from you for a while and
it's almost like they're ashamed to call
you because maybe they they relapsed or
they went back and they say it's okay
yeah right
because the reason why I say it's okay
because I take the the principle of our
Deen our Deen is redemptive this whole
this whole thing is about you being
redeemed from wrongs that we all wrong
ourselves every day we wrong ourselves
right this is just another aspect when
we just look at it okay call us you know
that mean you won that round you're not
gonna win the next round and I think
that's really what it is I looked at it
that way I've been off of our family's
been off of sugar for about six six plus
going on going on seven years now I look
at it like this sugar is like like
analogous to my nufs and we started off
on our feet got a takedown we grappled I
got to your back I got you in a rear
naked choke why would I even think about
letting you up right now right yeah
you're gonna now know my technique for
coming in on the takedown you're gonna
know my technique now for taking your
back and you're gonna be twice as
inspired and and have that type of rigor
that you're going to come at me with it
to prevent that from happening I feel
like that's when we make headway on
these things oh let me have a cheat day
it's a lie man days are like exactly
exactly I had a friend of mine as a
doctor boys in medical school he went
like 90 days without sugar
no cellar friend told now you deserve to
to you know to give yourself a break
stop being so hard on yourself
he said he won't do it I was never able
to recover from that oh that was it use
it right back to sugar just like taking
that taking that which you're not
supposed to take exact exact kid but you
can substitute it right you can do
healthy and great three four nothing
healthy in gurbani
you know you know dates
I mean you know stevia there's all kinds
of things that we can do but you know
look I love delicious food I love sweets
right yeah my kids are making that we're
making them at home
you know I mean so anyway well thank you
very much how do they later reward you
thank you guys for tuning in you know I
hit a lot of so we started why he just
kept saying he kept saying it now you
know handle aww look how simple it's not
a lot this is put in the crater first
and then we talked about tours in
honoring this vehicle that the Creator
has given us to get us through life and
leave us your takeaways in the comments
below subscribe if you haven't already
we'll see you next time here every week
with a new episode peace be with you
Salaam alaikum